for Western journalists killed by whose
air Baloch comes up on the TV and I'm
looking at him and he's looking at mean
he's guy I would never kill you don't
worry it's just the media and I'm going
we are the media
[Music]
we're in Karachi filming extreme world
and in a place called Li re which is a
no-go area for the police of Karachi
it's controlled by a man called or was
controlled by a man called Isaiah Baloch
he'd invited us into his house and while
I was on his roof doing a piece to
camera a sniper round from the police
went between me and the camera so we
both hit the ground said the rest the
other crew we creep downstairs whose air
was very upset about this and sent that
his own militia I mean he has I know
about 2,000 armed men at his disposal
we were then presented pushed into a
room downstairs but TV screen was on
given tea and all outside the bangbang
is going on and I see in English it says
for Western journalists killed by who's
there Bloch comes up on the TV and I'm
looking at him and he's looking at me
he's going I would never kill you don't
worry it's just the media and I'm going
we are the media all of a sudden the
lights go out at that point you're meant
to dive to the corner of the room in
case a flashbang comes in what did I do
found a cigarette lighter and lit it and
Kara we carried on filming and once we
got out of Lyari
we decided there was still some daylight
left we'd do some driving shots and
walking shot so I got out of the vehicle
and the cameraman was filming me from
the vehicle when the tuk-tuk stopped the
two women fully kind of in perder
functions go which I could see that she
had blue eyes and she looked to meet you
hi you Grom mutual and she was there a
girl from Birmingham that was living
just on the outsides of Liara she's met
a nice guy who came from Pakistan and
she's moved back to live there
grant mutual international superstar
you